I did a stream last night as news
breached the wires of Donald Trump's
Federal indictment and one of the
individuals who we watched live have a
complete and total mental breakdown on
live television was this Fox News host
Mark Levin who some consider to be a
great legal analyst I have not seen a
meltdown like this in years on media of
any kind you've got to see this here is
Mark Levin essentially saying this is
nonsense Trump is innocent they're going
after him for politics this guy should
maybe try decaf and
finds business partners Bob olinsky who
ties Joe Biden to the crimes Mr Big Mr
10 and what does Biden say well then
where's the money he's asking us come
and Catch Me If You Can the idea that
this man is is an under criminal
investigation and that they criminalize
the damn document case to go after
Donald Trump is sickening and I would
say this to our fellow Americans This
was by the way during the Hannity
program Hannity just standing by during
this entire thing don't be Bamboozled by
these cable channels and these fools who
come on and tell you like this guy he's
not above the law are you kidding me
Democrat attorney general in New York
Democrat prosecutor in Manhattan
Democrat prosecutor in Atlanta Democrat
attorney general in Washington D.C what
do you mean he's not above the law there
is no law what's going on here is a
disgusting disgrace it is war on Trump
isn't this the best it is war on the
Republican party and it is a war on a
republic the radical left is doing what
the radical left does while they cover
up for Biden the way they covered up for
Hillary cover up what bring evidence of
crimes they seem Furious that other
presidents or presidential candidates
aren't also getting indicted just
because it looks like Trump committed
crimes here is that this went on the
reviewers who were tuning out and then
tuning back into the stream and Levin
was still going tell you something there
are tens of millions of us you have
crossed the Rubicon twice which has
never been done and we will never
forgive you never ever and that's the
bottom line I'm done all right and so he
was done but we'll go back and look at
just a couple other moments just a
really tough night for Mark Levin
they're throwing all the all the process
crimes and all these crimes that grow
out of the criminal investigation
against Trump what did he do with the
documents did he sell them to the Enemy
No that's why we have an Espionage Act
not a trick of a president what did he
do did he burn them all no the
government has all the documents back so
there is no violation of the
presidential records act at this point
but they throw the book at them they go
after his attorneys they make them
testify their attorneys under the crime
fraud exemption to attorney-client
privilege that means he didn't have due
process his own lawyers were being
subjected to interrogations and they had
hundreds of in a person all right I
think you get it and then putting a
final point on it Mark Levin talking
about Trump's age
president Trump was 76 years old
if the Department of Justice gets his
way he will die in federal prison now of
course I don't believe that that's going
to happen I don't believe Trump is going
to do a single day of prison time I've
said it before I continue to believe
that if I'm wrong I will eat my
microphone but I don't think Trump's
going to be doing any prison time at all
an incredible 24 hours in America we are
going to be covering Trump's uh
arraignment as as it will will be on
Tuesday at 3 P.M Live on YouTube twitch
and Facebook it is happening ladies and
gentlemen a now twice indicted and soon
to be twice arrested Donald Trump will
find himself in federal custody before
he knows it Tuesday in a federal
courthouse I hope you will join us for
it this is accountability at least the
possibility of accountability for many
alleged misdeeds and that is a good
thing we're going to take a break what a
program we have for you today